you
you
you
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to GameSpot I am Nick margarita and I am
sitting here with the Matt Espen le yes
URL it's going well man how you doing
and today we're gonna be playing a
little for honor season - yeah we are
we're gonna jump right into it play some
of these new heroes the shinobi and the
Centurion who are all pretty swell in
their own unique ways this is pretty
exciting
because I feel like these two characters
are pretty unique compared to what was
the the base characters existing at for
honor at launch yeah totally totally
they it's interesting the way that they
kind of specialized them so the shinobi
is very much a he's got the longest
range in the game in terms of his
attacks while the Centurion needs to get
up close but he has all these crazy
options to flush through the flustered
opponents and stuff right so so we're
gonna get into some Dominion to start
yeah might as well
it's the mode that I enjoy the most in
the game just so everybody knows also
we're in the YouTube and twitch chat as
well as well as a site I believe so
if you guys have any questions for
myself or Matt please send them my way
hello to everyone in the chat he's
already there hello hey friends how are
you
just a word of warning we've been
getting booted from a couple matches
here and there
yeah it's commonplace for Ferranti
unfortunately at times so yeah there
there might be some instances where
we'll get somewhat far and then just get
booted so so just in case we get booted
everybody knows you know maybe it's a
new season two thing maybe it's a for
honor thing but just in case we get
booted stick around we're not going
anywhere
yeah so who is between the shinobi and
the Centurion which one is your favorite
so far oh man actually like them both a
lot but I definitely the shinobi just
because of the fact that he has all of
these like crazy like maneuverability
options and
and he's also very quick and as I said
yeah he's got a lot of range but all
that does come at a cost which is one of
the reasons why I think he's super fun
interesting to play as is that like you
have all the stuff you can do but if you
aren't efficient the way that you do it
you're gonna run out of stamina super
quickly right and you then your opponent
will just have a complete opportunity to
just destroy you so you were saying that
kind of the Shinobi's dodge moves where
he kind of does this cloud this kind of
smoke bomb yeah like smoke bomb that
takes up about a third of your stamina
something like that I feel like you can
only manage to do that about like three
times so if you spam it you're gonna be
out of stamina like right way quickly so
so these new carrot well especially
shinobi isn't exactly a character that
if you like to just spam r1 can't do
that anymore yeah pretty much should
definitely be more methodical with your
stuff that said he's also very fast so
like if you do kind of just switch up
your directions your opponent if they
don't know how to deal with you they're
just gonna be totally flustered so right
hello to super normal mode who's in the
chat right now hello I think that's uh
our friend and neighbor Miguel
concepción is it oh gosh
i'ma go hello Miguel I hope you're
enjoying III judges week all right so
let's see how many people chose new
character lessons just me and there's
another shinobi on my team so to
shinobi's on our team and then looks
like all classic characters yeah yeah is
that is that a female shinobi there I
believe that's what they call a kunoichi
that's a Japanese
crazy anyway that's a statue my weed
color no you know what you cultured I
just don't look bad whoa whoa try to
make you feel favorite Oh kidding right
alright let's are you gonna do the
Naruto run damn right I am
oh yeah I've got it it's lost him and
then all the stamina is gone
yeah alright all this points a little
bit it's also important to note that
there are two new maps as well I know
one is called Forge and the other is uh
was it's a temple garden temple oh yeah
that's right it's a temple garden gives
me that way oh noes
yep see this is why I said warning we've
been getting booted a little bit here
and there but hey you know what we
captured one point did we made some
progress there that's something to be
proud about
so hopefully that what happened too many
more times but uh yeah well it's okay as
long as I get that you know fight some
dudes yeah happy I mean if we have to we
could always fight the computer the CPUs
not as much fun ya know yeah they aren't
as much fun at all but yeah yeah result
what we got do you know I think a couple
people in the chat are asking about
destiny too as well I know
gameplay is on its way so if you guys
are looking for that very soon very soon
the guys in LA Erte I think they were
sending the files up here so we can put
them on the youtubes and everything so
don't forget to Like and subscribe on
youtube so you can see all the destiny 2
content that's coming your way but in
the meantime we'll just be in this
matchmaking room waiting however long I
look at my non-existent watch I am happy
I expected a lot of people on the chat
to be upset that we got booted
everyone seems to be on the same page oh
that was quicker than last time
all right I think it's the same map
don't know yep sanctuary bridge whoa
look at that they got all these cool
like head pieces and stuff the gear like
I've had some bad luck and it's a good
gear in this game really yeah like every
single time it's always just kind of the
basic stuff uh that headdress on the
left is pretty pretty badass yeah yeah
looks like that before yeah yeah it's
pretty pretty intense all right we got a
bot on their team
fingers crossed let's keep it up
ah let's looks like Kenny 30s asking
just for honor have dedicated servers
not sure they do yeah I'm not sure about
that any ice I could give you when you
wouldn't quote me on it yeah Sam that
might be something to look up cuz I mean
I can provide a chart with it oh yeah
looks like somebody says that it maybe
at that war drum soundtrack alright
alright tik-tok can we stay in this
match let's do it
son of it alright before we can get in
there
I've been happening this much on your as
well yeah my desk has been happening a
little bit too man I mean try yeah it
strike deathmatch different kind of me I
think dominions a little bit more
demanding let's do some skirmish fire
bucket says don't windows error please I
agree I prefer not this is just just as
bad though ma'am oh man
it's kind of a fortune I didn't
encounter allow this one the game first
came out and I had heard a lot of sort
of issues from some other game other
people have been playing the game or
saying like disconnects all that time
and I'm like yeah we had quite a run
here in the office to the NAT type for
for honor and a lot of Ubisoft games is
a little bit difficult so yeah yeah we
got a was we have to basically get our
certain like internet connections like
verified by some dudes over yeah I'm
office somewhere so but man when this
game runs it's really fun
yeah totally super fun it has a lot of
highs I didn't place them a lot when it
first launched and then I hopped in for
season two because I wanted to have the
opportunity to try out the Centurion and
shinobi right it's really fun then
honestly I liked the campaign too I
thought it was pretty interesting you
liked the campaign I know now I bet you
no one is gonna buy it but maybe it's
because every game I tried to play
online I was getting smoked to that
played and so I enjoyed the campaign cuz
let me learn right right yes it's
definitely a good training mode that's
for sure
but like because I actually got the
opportunity to review the game for site
and yeah one of my problems in the
campaign is that it kind of stretches on
a bit too long yeah points and also Auto
for a game that like tries to like you
know make a story out of like the three
most iconic warrior classes in you know
human history yeah how do you combine
those yeah it did its best but it just
got really weird and not convoluted but
just like heart like I couldn't get
attached to it yeah you know looks like
we have a Centurion on our team yeah
good because if I was fighting a
Centurion then that would be a problem
because yeah because the whole things
like Centurion is the perfect counter to
should I be technically right so they
released these two characters to counter
one another but so no Centurion on that
and their side so I'm happy all right
everyone fingers crossed all right come
on
just keep into this game cuz own life
want it use the shinobi and run around
like Naruto geez let us in on problems
no ho-oh-oh
animation seems to have stopped and one
person just left oh one other has left
oh wait I give it a second please oh
great and those are all the people okay
I mean I'm okay with it
well it seems to be me and doom robot
3000 oh and now they're all gone Oh what
come on
Oh No maybe knows oh my gosh Wow well
this is actually this is going quite
well it spins almost 15 minutes and uh
okay I don't really oh man okay um maybe
dual maybe one on one I mean that's like
the most base things very state they
would be like it would seem like it
would be very stable I mean we meant we
might not be very good at one V once but
hope came found that was quick for
medium activity very sorry about this
guys looks like the games been
disconnected a whole bunch yeah that's
right we're using AOL this is dial-up
internet yeah yeah we stole CBS
Interactive
they can't you can't hear this but to
sound and uh oh by the way sorry that I
didn't tell you what we are playing on
we're currently playing on PlayStation 4
yeah not PC uh so anyone that says it's
the windows crashing I promise it's not
alright I'm interested to see who they
picked oh okay
got some ken saying basically the
standard samurai class very well
balanced
all right fingers crossed again friends
we apologize for any inconvenience
caused that we have now wasted 15 of
your then it's okay come on all right
this has this has the one this is like
icing the kicker you've had too much
time please
let's fight let's fight got those Sakura
petals oh my god
oh no okay I'm gonna let you match make
I will be right back yeah check on
something see if anything's ever using
the right cable alright so I'm gonna
keep trying at this and um just see how
it goes really sorry about this guy's
light versus player let's do Dominion
again it's weird because it actually was
working out okay this morning when I was
playing around and I'm really feeling
the brunt of what a lot of firown' our
players were experiencing yeah just
trying to jump into any of these modes
honestly okay uh we can try one last
time for matchmaking if it doesn't work
out then we'll just do using bots or
something some computer okay come yeah
sorry again guys I don't really know
what's going on with the matchmaking or
the servers but
this is a real pain for both us and yeah
I'm you actually really really want to
play some of this game right now so
we're just as frustrated as you are so
sorry um all right game found joining
fingers crossed see these these are my
fingers they're crossed just a very high
activity
yeah right dad it's probably reason
money huh sorry Edward he says he's
leaving all Edward Kenway sorry ma'am
got a wander the sees its name name of
an essence before oh is it
Edward Kenway one of my fav one of my
fav is acid my favorites Sanskrit - is
my favorite game yeah that one was
really great mostly because it was just
such a great jump from the first game
you know what I mean in terms of quality
and Florence is the coolest city in the
whole world
Florence oh yeah before ok maybe want to
visit Italy like incredibly badly
alright alright let's try I'm gonna be
not optimistic for this one okay because
I feel like it's it's the this psych
psych out you know like if I say it's
gonna work then it doesn't work but if I
say like oh it's probably not gonna work
then it usually does work it's like
reverse psychology I can note it thinks
that you don't believe in it so
therefore it'll work
alright okay all right how we doing on a
point this looks like we just lost a so
I'm gonna go for that guy you lost okay
you really good at that
maybe next answer so war honor to Matt
Espen le he should uh should do the
voice you do the voices you hear they do
be soft you're watching right now you
heard that here first and free and you
should get dedicated service it'll be my
first whip
oh whoa hello alright hey buddy
oh nice in that distance game oh there's
some long-range
oh [ __ ] whoo all right slushies fellow
Oh got two boys of - Oh got three boy
maybe we should leave
somebody should help oh no revenge
please oh no it didn't oh my god
oh that's over oh okay chumps you know
what we didn't get kicked so didn't I
think it's a success I died either way I
thought people we're still doing it all
right oh I got revived oh nice
well looks like everyone picked up the
pieces here's that ranged attack you got
zone again right looks like they got
yeah we gotta get B since we should know
B I'd do things myself
whoops whoa that that group attack love
that's how I take scared like the
Randall like AI soldiers just sometimes
just kicks them like that it looked like
you were like a train smashing through
of Rome no stamina probably relax a bit
we did what
ah well I spoke too soon
we did we got too much for believing
we're gonna hop on some TV calm PvE
pvd's come yeah um okay let's see uh
sorry what am i doing we can base
building and custom yeah yeah and then
maybe we can actually show off some of
the new maps here huh yep so this is
actually a good thing that's true what
what day at time of day do you want it
to be we'll do all three so I guess
we'll start with day daytime like it is
now daytime all right okay again sorry
to those watching that wanted to see
some PvP the server's don't seem to be
kind today yeah let's do a little
skirmish with these fellas Matt was
having issues back at his desk and here
what can be very demoralizing when
you're just trying to like level your
character and just get some you know
some gear
yeah knowing just surprised at how like
skin wasn't honestly the felt honestly
didn't really encounter this one or do
you ad BOTS uh yeah
leaf so they're all just oh crap maybe I
didn't
yeah effed it so but level whatever
level you want and then random just do
something yeah you should be good there
it is now it's in there so you can do
one one-on-one or we're how you gonna do
it um we have I get these guys I don't
play a lot of bots as you can see just
pick these guys yeah it's kind of how
cheese goes so now you get one on one
team one on the other
gotcha okay that makes sense you can add
one more so it's what - V - yep yeah and
wait so just keep doing yeah you gotta
keep doing it yeah cuz if you're gonna
do um Dominion you'll need four and four
three and four let's get a Centurion
inside thing and just gonna lob huge
variety fellows cool alright so I think
that is good
kevin says it's okay don't be sad
GameSpot man I am sad I am sad too we
just said we just want to play some for
honor season two which costs $40 for the
season pass you just want to play yeah
online
oh yeah and speaking of which in terms
of like the specifics and details and
whatnot like the season like all these
new heroes like you can get them you can
get them with the season pass like
apparently like seven days early so
which means that like you do get at and
if you don't have the season pass you do
get access to these new heroes just
seven days after the season pass holders
right and then you have to buy them with
in-game currency which is about 15,000
steal I believe which is a hefty amount
of still fair amount so how long would
you say that would take that's a clean
online probably a little while actually
maybe that's not like a few matches
that's for sure
yeah all right let's do it eh I maybe
should have followed that other AI okay
stick together gotta be all these just
like randos or some heroes others here
up there on here's here right here okay
whoo no Pig
oh boy oh oh I'm gonna get crowded here
like bought Tony amico oh boy okay
no honors yeah right that's the whole
thing is that is a bit of an etiquette
online if you play vehicle where they
don't crowd a lot of people were saying
that when you've got three on one
they had no honor yeah all there we go
nice and long range to come back I'm
gonna inflict my duty on you friend it's
a Naruto reference what are you a big
Naruto fan actually I'm not I just did
ironically huh this like my girlfriend's
uterine Arthur now or she was she was a
younger person what's behind you oh boy
I just like dude whoever remember these
guys they're in like the single player
they don't exist on online yeah I don't
ya think is just kind of a way to
balance out everything so again right if
you have any questions or if you want
Matt to play a certain character and
test something out is also worth noting
the shinobi has the lowest health form
in the game so he's a bit of a glass
game yep so they are a little weak yeah
stamina and the health side but gosh
they're fun to play as though so quick I
think that's my favorite whoa hey buddy
okay oh nice I want to do the innocent
scorpion action here come over here
get after him
where did it go
oh here some action oh boy he big ho
doing a lot of unlockables here again
flustered going after him not you
Oh their antennae come up for you oh oh
no there's a lot of them here you got to
choose your battles oh that's the wrong
way let's see let's calm down a bit I
think they're smart enough to just
follow me do we know what these weapons
that the shinobi uses what they're
called uh was that they're also neo as
well charisa gamma camp don't quote me
on that may pronounce that horribly or
mix things up and are they connected to
each other or is it just there on chains
on one arm chained to another arm
basically yeah so like he has to usually
traditionally I think they you don't
that like a samurai will only light red
with samurai ninja will mean like
brandish one right and so like the way
it works is that uh yeah sickle attached
to chain and then the other end is
attached is a weight which you kind of
spin around and like used to like Juke
up the enemies yeah and Oh with that
interesting tidbit of history
I was not super focused on defense okay
hello bots love we meet again oh oh boy
[ __ ]
you okay
yeah I'll say after playing with this
shinobi he's so quick he or she cuz he
kind of she that's true um he or she is
super quick and so even if you're down
in a battle and your health is low and
you obviously have the one of the lowest
health pools they can have that quick
flurry oh boy that was not as quick on
the wine of that I thought I was going
to be those quick flurries are deadly
even for the big guys
Oh got a little bit of film now water
onto teaming up
hey man doggies and when it's when it's
when it's BOTS yeah Kevin was wondering
if they were originally garden tools
originally garden tools no I don't I
could see that being no I can't see that
being realistically a thing but I could
see someone use doing that doing using
one of these for that very perfect just
funsies one of our community managers
Ben is talking about how he likes that
for Honor's kind of always introducing
new characters new classes but he's a
big fan of the warden the warden oh yeah
who is your face so vanilla night Oh
called out vanilla night sorry Ben I
understand why you played one I guess oh
geez just hit him up I don't know if I
put them in the highest bot AI then
again when we went to Ubisoft to visit
and play a little bit of season 2 I
think we played with some of the bots
and one game yep got beat up pretty
we got destroyed pretty good yeah so
sometimes it's not that bad maybe not
turn up yeah yeah throttle right up
about there's a point where coordination
comes in handy for Dominion especially I
think we weren't really covering points
oh oh ben says wow want to fight about
it yeah I do and for honor let's do it
maybe a little one-on-one duel yeah
oh boy just we just it would have to be
loading it well yeah we have broken them
whoa whoa what happened swing three down
some stuff alright looks like me almost
winning this round okay gotta get out of
that ring very closely so Kevin wants to
know what your favorite character is I
get a pre and post DLC I see uh oh geez
oh okay yeah this is terrible question
comes or answer coming soon uh my
favorite character and actually the one
that I do use that did use before the
Uni PLC was o-jama Type O was no bushi
which is the spear wielding girl I
realized there's a bit of a stigma with
that character I mean slightly at least
from what I've assumed because she can
be kinda I remember hearing stuff of
balancing issues with her right uh but I
love using her because like I just love
ranged characters which is one of the
reasons why with this new DLC I am
starting to really love the shinobi I
just love playing that game with people
unlike kind of playing to sort of keep
away
yeah with them and I know I like I'm
sure that's like a nuisance to like the
opponent but like I just
one of the things that like comes to
mind for me whenever like I real it when
I realize I like playing he's kind of
care does the thing that came to mind
that they did realize that was that I
just played a lot of Street Fighter 4
super Street fire for back in the day
and I played the care I'm East the main
Cody and all this things that he has a
knife in the field that he can pick up
which adds a little bit to his range and
one of things I love doing with Cody was
picking up the knife in the middle
around and then just basically not
letting an opponent get near me at all
but just like slicing them up from a
distance so yeah I realized that and I
was like wait nobody's really cool and
that totally fits with what I like Cody
so that's why I use Nobby she well I see
Ben said his is his favorite samurai
might be the Nobu she yeah at least you
have something common right totally let
me throw best part of no but she is that
she can inflict poison on enemies so one
of the great things is like especially
in the duel is uh what is it using like
the poison on it against somebody and
then realizing that the poison is
literally gonna deplete them to death so
then like right around still going and
he's like what are you doing and I'm
just like running away from the or like
just like kind of walking away for them
and they look we what and then they die
yeah it's the best feeling ever
especially in a duel so should we
oh yeah with Centurion this round yeah
that's a few do some Centurion come let
me just try to show that off for camión
zombies is asking if we can try
multiplayer again will do um we'll do
another skirmish just so we can showcase
the Centurion skills and kind of his his
loadout and then after that we can try I
guess yeah yeah here we try again with a
duel keep it simple well yeah definitely
duels no more more like exciting anyway
- so but yeah
duels are my favorite yeah we played a
lot at Ubisoft 2v2 duels and we kept it
very very much for honor right it was
one on one one on one and whoever
survived you just got to wait your turn
wait your turn to fight and you survived
would fight the other side and it was
pretty fun yeah yeah had a good time now
Centurion he is much bulkier and he
right yeah and it's he does in his range
isn't incredible so like you really have
to get up close to the enemy oh geez oh
boy I should also preface this I haven't
played a lot of steering but I do love
the stuff you can do I can if I'm able
to showcase it it's like that guys and I
showcase a little bit of what since
hearing community I love the art style
and the armor and everything about this
Centurion I think it's so cool it's got
that that Roman like that Roman looked
to it yeah totally silly whether it fits
into the aesthetic of the rest that came
I'm not really sure I thought that he
stood out a little bit a little bit too
much right yeah you know like shinobi
yeah that's that's totally yeah it's a
samurai's samurais and goku era you know
but the with the knights and stuff you
just suddenly get a octarine yeah roman
miter like a Roman warrior yeah it's so
different oh hi oh this is um uh this is
an interesting question Tobias wants to
know should I buy this for honor for ps4
I guess the season pass or does he wait
till next month to purchase arms for
switch oh it just so happens that I'm
talking to right guys kind of that Matt
and I went to an arms event last week we
did we did and we played a ton of it and
arms is pretty fun surprisingly I didn't
I really think much of it went first I
was like okay that's just like a kind of
novelty sort of motion control fighting
competitive game I was a hater - we went
in there I was like I'm not really
expecting money I have pretty low
expectations coming in there but we got
out of it oh jeez talking and playing
that game arms with my mind I'm
extremely excited for it
oh boy Oh Union Detroit Oh
whoa okay below no honors no honor here
at all
where's the rest of your team I don't
know and looks like we're on track to
lose so Oh God
it it's almost as if you're playing for
on one I haven't seen any other team
members and the score reflects it too
yeah yeah what's up with that where are
they there's one oh yeah okay let's just
stick guys to crown my buddies here oh
yeah nothing nothing knocking for honor
season two and whatnot but arms is a
really cool game so keep an eye out for
some gameplay that I've been working on
that Matt masterfully talked about for
us that'll be up soon so check that out
on gamespot.com oh and be sure remember
if you're on Twitch hit the follow
button if you're on YouTube hit that
subscribe button so you can be notified
when we go live and you'll know when new
videos come out new reviews new gameplay
yeah yeah get rekt getting I'm getting
all kinds of rekt can all kinds of
shrekt right now I think we know that
Matt is much better with the with the
shinobi yeah definitely these kind of uh
close range characters are still old
somebody's been playing a little too
much shinobi hey man I practiced a
little bit in the afternoon and we'll
know more like this morning to playing
since Aria when we went to visit Ubisoft
I think 75% of the time we were playing
as shinobi anyways yeah a lot a lot of
team ninjas
that said I do like what this interior
is capable of I was taking a look at
some of his move sets and practice and
stuff and like I do want to try to get
you better yeah but it doesn't seem to
be happening right here in front
everybody hey you know what you win some
you lose some
drastically lose some look at that look
at that sweet score we got here uh okay
you're right you're right else again we
are in the twitch and to chat inside
chat if you guys have questions
questions whatever it is you'd like to
stay say you can send them our way here
we go
well some good 1v1 it's close oh he's at
a scam now now he's running away dang it
come back here get him and that's the
ball game
oh yeah yeah camera noise and girls all
right so what do you say we hit up
matchmaking yeah and we try a little
dual action fingers crossed
let's do it also I I agree with gaming
zombies it is the Centurion kind of has
that Ryse son of Rome aesthetic oh yeah
is arm early totally kennels get like
one of those Lego head pieces if you get
there you can get a gear that basically
would make it makes it get what it week
that thing the top of every like Roman
soldier is like a helmet I don't even
know what that headdress is called I
don't even know does it have a name I
I'm sure it has a name I just don't know
it
alright as you can see in the background
we have this sweet I mean it's really
small in the pit we have this sweet
Roman sword check it out and let's write
it is a legit man even that has a name
and it escapes me but it's a short sword
oh the Roman sword yeah
you know how to name I'll look it up
let's see it's a little history fad
tidbits for y'all it's some history
since the server's keep crashing let's
say sure a clade yes is it glabius
or is it Gladius mmm I think it's
probably is I think it's Gladius yeah
let's have a little debate in the
comments section
even though how do you pronounce a tisha
the pronunciation is that way that old
video game series is called Gradius
because japanese aren't able to
pronounce oh we're in oh hey I see some
shinobi I already knew he was gone for
that shinobi hey man fingers cross
fingers cross fingers cross whoa I'm
fighting this fella if I had cinterion
this guy would've wrecked me it's guys
really good like a side dodged swipe
that he can do super quickly I'll use
orochy a lot this is what that class is
clone what I've noticed he's a easy fave
let us know in the comments what your
favorite foreigner character is too yeah
I'd love to know yeah that's you know
he's a baby I'm worried about how Opie
fish know he is alright time to focus
no talking mat range game just fighting
okay very nice
oh boy oh boy oh boy nice block alright
get you flustered friend again like I
was saying earlier even when the shinobi
gets real low in health okay there's
that like chance even when you have just
a little bit left there's a chance that
you can just have a quick flurry at the
end finish them off yeah get that real
come then round 2
all right friend let's do this out of
ten how much do we recommend this game
I'll tell you right now
I'm gonna check our review cuz I don't
remember oh yeah out of your friend Oh
whoo oh oh yeah Wow
- oh I'm impressed get in there
we're getting a lot of votes for the
Orochi whoo yeah yeah I can never I got
it I got trying some more I remember
liking my slang single-player back then
but when I was doing competitively it
wasn't really my cup of tea
whoa and for those of you wondering out
of ten how much do we recommend this
time is it gonna be dip for honor will
you lose I get punished this is my
precious Steam reviewer
mr. Matthew has been on your mister or
side oh yeah gold you had to give an
eight I actually quite enjoyed this game
come here buddy
oh no don't call it a comeback your head
is missing oh my head is really missing
good fight good fight remember guys
whenever you're in a duel or when you
find anybody make sure it's a good fight
you know cuz it was one time I know I'm
passionate about these these duels you
know like especially when it's really
like tense riveting got to respect the
pro so we over here recording quite a
few votes for Orochi we have a couple
for Bob ringer we have one for Sombra
that's an overwatch character Tobias you
try to slip that one in on me huh so so
this is what happens when you don't
manage your Stan oh yeah oh but
nonetheless good boy
that was a grisly finishing move yeah oh
it looks like a one-man on the round
there's the good fight good fight
also didn't want to say it but we just
made it through a full round yes we did
no problem
all right let's get some cuts I've got a
little bit of gear here that's a level
one though it's pretty low let's see can
we can you pick the map or is it random
well I could do a map vote oh it doesn't
give us not all of the options are there
maybe just the two new maps are pretty
fantastic
I really like the temple garden right
it's really pretty so let's stay locked
at this guy because he wants to fight
again and I totally didn't distribute my
war assets so what are you gonna do here
oh you're gonna do it and try it I bet
you it's a smart move because he thinks
you're gonna be shinobi again right
right we're gonna we're gonna psych him
out let's see what he is but then again
if he plays shinobi than done
yep all right this is going swimmingly
no oh boy
range game uh gotta close in that
distance there's another good question
from Saints Kay what is everyone's
favorite faction samurai yep agreed yo
isn't a huge weed and how much how much
are the new characters to the season
pass is $40 yes it's about 40 ducks 40
bucks sorry not Dex Dex are cool too
they are oh hi oh oh very nifty what I
will say is it feel like I've been
saying that a lot today
sorry help hold it you can take a
significant amount of damage as the
Centurion ridicule and if you land a
couple like this oh poor guy he's just
trying to get some vengeance and you
wrecked him in round one again I did did
but like it seems like he's
I'm making too much use of his like I
think he's still trying to get
acquainted with his range
yeah I'm not I'm noticing is I using
loves manoeuvrability stuff Brady the
Beast duh beast I'm sorry
eighty nine wants to know if we beat
story mode I have uh I have yeah I
actually had two for the review Matt
obviously do it for the review um oh no
oh oh no I'm poisoned oh just the time
he tricked you
it's done like I was gonna literally die
if I didn't like I had to rush to kill
the guy who's sweet execution defeat and
I know I said it earlier I played a lot
of story mode just because I suck online
I was okay dude you just practice you'll
get there so yeah I use I used story
mode as kind of a way to learn round
practice yeah the game definitely a good
tutorial in that way alright alright
what is it 1 1 alright here we go
got that speed in okay no again pleasure
there's question is is there gonna be
any additional story along with the DLC
characters I don't believe so no
actually yes guy is Oh stamina oh oh oh
come on hoody watch out he's moving them
out you move it about good what that
stamina run down oh man woo this is good
I'm having a good time just like the
Queen song boy oh no oh no oh okay oh oh
wow that was good woo hoo that was that
was quite a match yeah my heart is
racing here I'm enjoying it Raun little
better there's a lot of a lot of intense
testosterone in this cake Wow
I do love these maps they're so just
like unique cooking and I reign looks
early lead Matthew here we go I play the
cover game that I was doing this with a
guy earlier in the game it's kind of
like strafing around covered
man this is gonna be yes done Oh game oh
oh yeah good night good fight good fight
look at me and I even fall in my my
etiquette here you think he's gonna come
on good fight - are you good sport he
doesn't have a chance to say anymore I
think he's gonna want a rematch it young
he might salty runback no loot Wow no
loot come on I want some sweet
headdresses unfair helmets that is a
good question who's gonna be the next
kind of like DLC character we would
assume it's got to be a Viking yeah but
I think they're gonna do two each time
so I wonder who else like amongst we're
talking about that it was a little
interesting that you'd introduce two
characters from to the separate classes
versus introducing three and having one
for each yeah is he fighting again oh
he's flat gets down to do it again I
mean I'm just gonna kind of take this
for as much like maybe we'll just do one
more with him and then we guess we'll
try another mode I guess I yeah sure are
we doing on time we doing okay yeah
we're doing okay
whoa um as long as it's okay with
everybody here if they can hear me a
game spot out there will run till about
3:15 ish since the first 15 minutes uh
we kind of wasted your guys as times
China yeah get through wonky servers but
um since we're up I'm running now well
we'll go an extra 15 minutes totally I'm
feeling lucky
yeah do this and because Matt is
straight killing it with both characters
well this is my counter though he might
be good at cinterion well if it was best
of three it's already over that's true
never is doing for funsies well best of
five that's two fives let's say oh boy
hello
that is a cool skin he's got for him
what we dodged nice think you learned
that from you
whoa get ready kick bro all right okay
oh he's gonna flustered Oh your stamina
is low exactly I get out of it oh I'm
dead ended oh okay
I don't know what happened there but I
think but I won so that could have been
bad you're in a corner I was cornered
now at this point you said good fight a
lot
I have do you think he's mocking you do
you think he thinks you're mocking him
now I hope not it's a good intention you
know I might I think you're mocking me
oh boy okay that ranged attack is a
deadly crumbly Oh blah oh oh this is his
chance Oh toe to toe don't try to run we
try to run he'll catch up
ha ha no blank Tia dusty alright yeah I
think he'll know it's good attention
when I say good fight when I'm gets ok
that make sounds you know respond oh man
I think it'll salty
I think he's salty because you've smoked
them no so far yeah that has happened
but I'm not um give me home about it you
know you did put up a good fight round 3
round 3 round 3 resto 5 what do you guys
think in the comments
the next DLC character where do you
think they're gonna if it is if it does
end up being a Viking character what do
you guys think it'll look like any
inspiration from like movies or TV oh
this shinobi makes sense but that's
Antarian it's bit of a stretch
oh nice block oh boy this little flurry
Oh get kicked all right somebody's
asking how much steel does the new
character cost that blooms at 15,000
steel it's a lot of steel that is
[Music]
alright back when you said it earlier I
thought you said 1500 and I was like
that's not that bad oh no 15,000 that is
significant don't know wow you had the
high ground he has a low ground what
happened okay now it's trendy some
stupid okay I'm oh yeah I'm suffering
for trying to do that I'd love to know
what you were trying to do there okay so
one of the fun things you can do with
Shinobi's that
when you're spinning around his his
sickle is that it in between you and him
there's a pit you can just like pull him
towards you and pull him into a pit
ah I do that don't be flashy and cool
but you see what happens to people who
try to be too stylish I see I look hot I
like the effort but just so you know
this is for all the marbles right here
that's true
oh no standard oh boy oh okay I got a
recovered oh Jesus
Saints K says gotta go see ya thanks for
joining us Saints yeah thanks man
we appreciate the hi good comments oh he
did fall good fight man
seriously Wow good fight nothing it come
on
five seconds two point six no I didn't
get to see it and he says no but I'll
take your salty runback anyway oh I
think that's an injured like your your
head is wrapped in bandages yeah from
all the battles was I ain't even good
for my stance exhaustion recovery yeah
take that all he left the session Oh was
salt a he must have heard what I said
best of five
you lost oh and three Matt wins and it
was a good fight though like he had me
on the ropes every once in a while I was
good
alright you ready to give it a try do
some Dominion fingers cause this will
work Brady the Beast says I'm subbing
now Thank You mr. Brady we appreciate it
and for everybody else in the comments
don't forget to Like and subscribe so
that you can see all our other feature
content future live streams features
reviews all kinds of exciting stuff hot
stuff
gamespot and everybody that came here
looking for destiny - don't worry we've
a ton of brand-new destiny - content
coming your way
later today sooner than later so soon
very soon and if you want to see all the
content that came out for destiny to go
to gamespot.com and we've compiled
cinematic trailers gameplay all the news
and stuff news clan news new weapons new
powers it's been a pretty pretty awesome
day in the video game community how do
you think I should pick shinobi's
terrianne for this I think you should
try out this new cool oh yeah yeah my
new eye cover thing totally away to have
another skill here stealth hmm that
sounds cool can hide my hide yourself in
the HUD cool and aim-assist legit
alright got got another shinobi dang if
only we were all shinobi then would be
just team ninja
oh just one or no so no yeah just go -
any idea we would totally probably do
this it's too many too many glass
cannons on one yep that is correct
gaming zombies don't forget to click the
bell icon because that's what gives you
notifications well that game spot of my
time working here I didn't notice that
until around like almost a year it was
like Oh can't believe it did youdid you
weren't even notified when you did your
awesome content I'm Sam is it is a sad
thing a lot of loss thing but at least
we're playing now we're all happy
right here a lot of exciting reviews you
guys can check out recently who Oh looks
like this match is already in progress
anta Jackie all right back to 1v1 duels
it doesn't Dominion just it doesn't it
doesn't want a family nice today we Wow
you know what you were crushing the duel
so I feel pretty comfortable deathmatch
don't feel comfortable - nope you share
too much going on cant handle let's keep
that 1 v 1 d 1 maybe 2 V 2 yeah I don't
even actually that's incredible activity
so yeah let's just keep one 1v1 we
should get somebody real good here I can
feel it
sure hope so I do I do admire the people
who still play duel because I think it's
I mean it's the most honor it does have
the most honor but it's kul don't seem
to be on it too much but I think it's
probably the better modes in the game
because it just it really highlights the
combat just kind of all on itself you
don't even have like your feats and
stuff that like give you enhancements in
the middle of battle it's just you and
your scale against their skin so I want
to see my cool head thing my head gear
so I'm gonna pick shinobi again what
what do you guys think in the comments
if you're doing a 2v2 duel and your
partner kills the other person do you
swoop in and gang up on the other person
or do you have honor and you kind of
chill on the sidelines and wait for that
battle to finish I'm not gonna lie I
didn't know that was adequate
you don't just people did it to me
you dog I couldn't I'm sorry man but I
know now ever since that time played
jean-luc I'm gonna honor people's 1v1
deal duels I have the high ground Anakin
welcome to my dojo yeah you've lost few
blocks I hate you Oh boys your rocky
24/7 and this is as far we're at again
Janaki
come on bro oh I see what you're doing I
think he knows oh okay
hope you know what you look pretty
badass up there just okay that's what
happens you've been played sir I have
been played you've been played it's got
electricity come here but anyway yeah
didn't work out I don't think I'm gonna
be able to make that happen
unfortunately I had to fall death for
them I didn't fall death I think this
should be enough all right here we go
oh whoa where is he going he doesn't he
doesn't want the high ground
oh he's aa boo-boo this guy he wants to
fight you on the bridge cheating and
push you off what's a bridge duel boo
this man oh oh oh I see what he's doing
here he's pushing my buttons I don't
like this guy Wow he plays with no
honoring outs Wow wait wait good fight
though gotta be nice no want to be super
salty even though I'm a little salty
right nope it's here for you friend
Elise oh I'm sorry but I'll say I don't
know I'm sorry I can't pronounce
anything says if you're if it it depends
if they're winning gang-up Ryan says if
you don't want that to happen there's a
1v1 Kat did you say cat I don't know
what that means and I know they were
cats and fur on me
it's part of the Ryan also said it's
part of the game help your team right
yeah I guess yeah no yeah totally like
in Dominion stuff I can see that
anything but like when I was playing
like with John Luke technically it was a
duel and I realize like oh I guess yeah
yeah just kind of wait are to each
other's turns and stuff okay focus oh oh
no dude this guy when I met your match
dang it doll I might have met my match
also I'm not useless this match up to Oh
defeat he's a good foot yeah he's blue
yeah that's good I'm happy for that
other guy didn't seem to respond too
much being polite man it's such an
underrated thing thunder having people
forget they certainly do alright let's
fight this guy again I feel like you
need to redeem yourself here yes I
believe a Redemption come on does he
want to do it again come on man you
Rocky 24/7 you got to have time for this
to do some fights I don't know his
connection seems a little walking sup
inbred is it his connection in yellow
yeah ah come on two out of three bro
yeah best of three always again we'll
play till about 3:15 since the first 15
minutes were spent in a riveting
riveting a matchmaking search so just
there's a lot there's drama there right
you know like what are they gonna find a
match I know you guys were loving I'm
sure the UH dislike bar on YouTube for
that first 15 minutes what's going up a
little bit I'm sure it was it's only
going up because you killed it during
the duel now it's pretty sick oh three
now yeah I guess I guess it's the thing
right sky sky akkad I thought said sky
rocket play the gladiator next
all right not actually gladiator but I
can see why you thought that why you
thought that yeah
it's he's just Centurion if I'm saying
that right I say that right
senator I can't imagine any other way to
say it Centurion on Centauri entering
Centurion no that that's not even let's
just call a TA turtle a dat ya official
alright in DC 95 got X's surrounding
your name some underscores alright very
i popular request hello to everyone on
the youtubes hello to everyone on the
twitch machine oh look at that we got
ourselves another Centurion and look at
his outfit he's got a bad thing that I
wish it just looks like a broom that's
what I was what say he's got the broom
maybe that's they call it the old broom
headdress boom head check we have a cool
sword right here just like there's what
is it like the leagues Lane Gladius the
Gladio yeah like matías oh he's getting
hyped oh man hi
he's got the Italian flag then does that
make sense he does oh geez okay I think
we know who's favorite character uh this
guy okay I don't know how I'm really
flustered right now because I'm not
abscond okay there you go
look II took no damage Oh No recover
stamina friend Oh
ooh ah goodbye goodbye goodbye
all right good fight Jaden just joined
the stream hello Jaden well welcome to
the stream welcome to the stream feel
like we should have a nice little
greeting like that right computer yeah
we say every time someone joins them or
we could do like four on early welcome
to the stream and again boy
we are playing for honor Oh season two
stop it stop it Fred stop it no it's
single what CK right I can't do it but
look what he's displaying there this is
one of the reasons why this material is
pretty legit it's like I I don't even
know it's doing so quick oh but I do
feel like he's doing the same three
things over and over and over again and
it's he's doing that little jump move
thing he's knocking you down and then
he's like jabbing you and then before
you can get up he's like restarted that
that trio again right right
he's a little similar to the Peacekeeper
technically he was another night see
look at me see he's rushing you
oh come on at me contact oh I know I do
that kick thing but just gonna do it oh
nice nice oh he's just deflecting
me yeah that's the whole thing about
this there knows that his attacks are
very focused on the fleeting stamina and
oh I'm in a huge depleted no man wreck
sorry guys
at least you get to see what he's
capable of it's just I'm not the one
who's delivering sieving you a rematch
but you play as shinobi no is I feel
like I'm give him a run Europe I don't
want to teach your horn cheese too much
but you're pretty good at this shinobi
Centurion not so much okay there's still
a lot of work to be done okay whoa got a
lemon no I'm ready so he wants oh he
wants a fight please do it
rematch two out of three ah nurses all
right nice all right
best of three this is this is what's
going to determine my my honor here
let's see can you can you vote for the
maps to learn Oh oh I think I might have
missed my opportunity to do that because
that was to you don't forget you guys
there are two new maps
it's the forge and the temple garden
those are the two new maps
I don't think we've really showed them
too much just not only in the bot the
bot matches earlier we did but I mean
the Maps sort of changed right like
they're more of like a theme and like
depending on the mode you play they look
very different but oh well apparently
people don't play the new maps I think
we know who's favorite character uh
Italian flag guys yeah maybe just a
little bit I think we know all right
penalize a fellow Italian I am a little
bit jealous of his his shield it's
pretty creative I didn't even think of
that
Oh in that kick thing but you can get
away uh-oh
I feel like if he lands one gloriani
your guns uh he's closing the distance
oh my gosh there it goes
no no you're okay no no damn oh oh wow
he's very used that he's that thing
don't get cornered no he is so good for
close-range [ __ ] Oh into that sticky
lunge all over over there
good fight good fight boy oh boy
he'll be trying he say yo he did yo yo
what's up I'd like to continue this
conversation but I don't think we're the
emails to support it it ends it yo yo
okay
okay got focus
scheisse o's down is gone stamina you
don't forget guys the shinobi has the
lowest stamina and health but he's good
he's good
good cinterion he's doing his job this
gentleman knows how to play the
Centurion but do you think he knows how
to party I don't know I don't know him I
just thought that that was like
connected I know to play and party don't
get pushed off here oh boy try not to
this is a dangerous place to look to be
nice I feel like you got to get a flurry
in like that and then get back yeah let
that stamina replenish and then grab and
pull man I have the high ground Anakin
oh yeah oh my take that my jutsu
there it is ooh come on send up some a
little like yeah I got you using a my my
pose I love how like he crosses his arms
and like I understand like it show me
like that Stern ninja but I can't help I
think it's like a b-boy pose you know
I'm sorry
dancing check it out guy akut said it's
not possible to beat the the gladiator
face on but you just did
can he do it can he do it again he's
cornering me though you're a Bloxom who
Manik Khan shot he's taunting you when
we push a Game five
Oh whoo yeah
oh no he pulled me hang on whoa nice
move nice little dodge nice oh wow it's
over guys Cindy blocks a thousand how
about we do one more duel and then we
will call I mean it's up to him if he's
down a day all right yeah if he says
well we'll fight one more time then
we'll do it if not we'll end and bring
things to a little conclusion you can
take anything cool she can give you
something it's level one super low what
does it do for me
revenge gain okay what no no Callum no
ready please best of five men 5 do it
for the fun dude he's like there's no
challenge
oh good sport I hope he's a good boy I
think he's being with his boy all right
let's do this match up again I feel like
if you pick Centurion again oh you know
it you know yeah it's a good display of
uh these need get these new heroes
though I see that we see the matchups
here yeah so uh I guess for a run in the
chat who do you guys uh prefer after
seeing the shinobi in the Centurion what
do you guys whether you've played or not
buddy what do you guys think is the
cooler new character class the new
so to speak and sorry Jaden
we are not switching games I think there
are a couple guys that do zelda-esque
show but not today
sorry today we have for honour we had a
little bit of destiny earlier today
right right consider that salmon a
little bit oh can he eat get out here
no you should have pushed them off try
it no he countered he countered my uh my
uh my guard break oh that is wolf got
zombie fight he's good fight we got a
couple couple votes for shinobi is their
favorite so far
nice okay is a legit character and he
countered that he knows he has my number
I don't even give it sounds good I like
that
okay should be using that anymore
stamina oh that wasn't good it wasn't
very my train yeah your clothes I'm not
sure you can take him on your love too
much yeah I just got it yeah which is
well the distance game ladies and
gentlemen uh Matt is down to his final
death can he come up with three wins in
a row here can I will I I'll be taking
bets
oh let money go to you friend all right
here we go I'm just gonna try to play
primarily just again Oh gaming Tommy
says you got no chance Matt Sean Oh
show em what you got okay okay okay
don't get cocky don't uh-oh he knows oh
wait
whoa yeah okay doesn't win a lot of
people bet no let's do it come on Matt
let the people know the people know show
them oh oh no oh no don't tell me they
they're in connections at the last day
oh no this is the end that was a decent
movie it's okay
oh okay okay yeah okay gotta focus we
get all right focus in did oh he knows
my number
all right oh you're letting them in
close knock is a little bit more confine
uh oh right uh oh no it's done and it's
all over folks
you were right it's all over oh we could
fight good fight good fight okay ladies
and gentlemen thank you so much for
joining us it's hard not to be salty but
okay cool
it was a bumpy ride it was we had a
little bit of uh a rough start and uh
you know we got into some some really
good stuff we showed you guys for honor
season to the Centurion we showed you
the shinobi Matt did a bunch of duels
crushed our first matchup had a quite a
battle to end the stream yeah but
overall what are your final thoughts on
season two I like it a lot
and it's definitely gonna bring me back
into the game a little bit cuz kind of
stopped a little because I was gonna
busy playing other games but I
definitely want to come back in here try
to get better at the shinobi and maybe a
little bit the Centurion but doing it
join it a lot a lot of games out right
now
but I want to thank you guys for joining
us be sure to check out if you want to
see mats for honor review that's on
gamespot.com and you can find all kinds
of really cool content there and don't
forget if you're on Twitch hit that
follow button so you guys will know when
we go live in the future and if you're
on youtube hit that subscribe button
that like button thank you guys so much
for joining us and we will see you next
time so take care everyone
Boop love you later you guys